chasin what has been your strategy in
seeking out acting teachers or coaches
well I didn't have one for a while after
school because i was taking myself I've
had three years of people telling me
what to do and how to act and I learned
a lot to get me wrong but I thought I
want to kind of be myself for a while
and then I didn't get anything for a
while and I was just trying to figure
out how to live by my lonesome out of
college and then earlier this year I I
just thought you know what I think it's
time I start an acting class again even
if just to have a place where I can do
it every week so that I'm obligated to
act every single week and I'm keeping it
sharp you know it's like as an act if
your workout you got to work out every
week unless maybe you've had it bunch
and you gotta have a deal owed week
that's a different topic and so and I
was quite I lucked out actually because
I've been writing down a lot of acting
teachers in schools I was planning on
trying out a lot of them but I had a
friend who I he just told me about this
acting teacher he had and I thought oh
I'll interview her see how I like her
and I went to her apartment and she
interviewed me to see if I was right for
her class and I just got this this vibe
from her like I was like I click with
this person this person speaks my
language and I like the way they look at
it and I think we're good match and she
was making all these observations about
me that I didn't know you could make if
he didn't know me for a long time I'm
not talking cold reading i'm
talking like real deep observations and
so I started going to her class and for
now I'm just sticking it with her I mean
maybe a long while in the future I might
try out some other stuff and a do thing
you got to expose yourself to different
people but for now i'm content being
with this person so it sounds like you
took a break because you were so it was
so intensive when you were at lambda and
then you just wanted to do some stuff on
your own and you realize that just
finding someone that intuitively you
matched with mm-hmm was probably the
best thing it wasn't necessarily a style
right meissner or oh yeah she kind of
has her own way of working that she's
derived from various people she's worked
with cheese russian jewish and pretty
old
she met Turkish key andrei tarkovsky the
famous Russian director and like she's
so she's been around uh-huh and she she
was taught by some people who were
Michael Chekov students she might have
had a teacher too who was a Stanislavski
student from like directly from him
there's one guy in particular who she
really really likes so it was one of
Stanislavski students who Stanislavski
said it was a better teacher than him
and I think she was taught by a couple
of Meyer hold students as well so a lot
of the rush a lot of the Russians she
likes but also her own methods from
various people she's worked with and
practices and so your advice to another
young actor out of school sounds like
find somebody that you just really
resonate with as a person uh-huh yeah
and like don't be afraid to try
different people and ask them questions
and uh if you feel like their answer
doesn't make sense to you then then move
on and I also say when you're looking
for a teacher you're don't look for
someone who you think is just going to
make you good right away it will just
get you famous or get you work right
away you know it's a process you know
this is not a get-rich-quick scheme you
know look for someone who is going to
challenge you and and and work because I
think a lot of people just want to start
getting work right away which is fine
don't deny it if it comes but you know
not everyone's ready right away and you
just got to really be confident what
you're doing before you start trying to
get everyone to like you it's not it's
not a weekend real estate course no okay
yeah you want to make sure that you feel
comfortable there and what if someone
let's say they don't they've been in the
class a little bit and there's just
something or they just don't feel right
one should they make that break and go
to another one wouldn't know everyone
else likes it when you can you know be
polite about it don't burn a bridge
don't don't insult them or anything but
just say you know i'm i'm still trying
to figure out who i am as an actor and
I'm trying to maybe try different people
and and just see what happens i just
want to see what else there is out there
I think if they're any good or if
they're any if they have any
understanding they'll understand that
you know they understand and like you
got to find your own path and find
resonates with you as long as you're
respectful about it and you just say I'm
just trying to see what else is out
there you know if you're a dick about it
you say you suck of course they're not
going to they're going to be angry at
you so did ya just use prudence I'd say
but don't don't ever stick with so I
mean don't leave just because you're
feeling like it's harder because it's
challenged you know i'd say give it a
good go before you really decide that
it's not right for you because who knows
maybe at first you're it doesn't feel
right just because you're being
challenged or maybe you're just being
put out of your comfort zone but after a
while if you really don't think you're
getting results then you know then try
something else
you